[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH CARSON: My dissertation
is titled "Ungovernable Winds,
the Weather Sciences in South
Asia from 1864 until 1945."
GYAN PRAKASH: Sarah as
a student is everything
that one could hope
for and imagine.
So when she came in, she came
in with great credentials.
And she's kind of lived up
to all our hopes and more.
SARAH CARSON: I started
to become interested
in this subject --
I think it's a convergence
of several interests
that I've harbored for a
long time, starting with --
well, I come from
a very conservation
and environmentally
inclined family
that does work in
environmental education.
GYAN PRAKASH: Sarah's
work brings into view
how the environment had
always been actually
an important part
of India's history,
but something that
was neglected.
SARAH CARSON: My
dissertation looks
at the history of the Indian
Meteorological Department,
using its records
and publications
to understand how scientists
employed by the state
tried to define and delimit
the atmospheric phenomena
above South Asia.
These maps show that
rainfall was really
the primary concern of
meteorologists in this time
period.
And they didn't map onto
political provinces,
so they could be considered
more like ecological or
climatological units.
I think I've been fortunate
to have picked a project that
resonates with people from
lots of different interests
and backgrounds.
And I think that
that's something that's
special about the weather.
GYAN PRAKASH: I think
her work will showcase
the importance of environmental
history, both scientifically
but also in its popular form.